Here with me now is Secretary
of State Antony Blinken.
Thank you so much for joining me today.
This march
within 120 miles of Moscow, Prigozhin
then abruptly stopped, turned around
yesterday afternoon.
What happened?
Why
Dana, we don't
have full information, obviously,
and it's too soon
to tell exactly
where this is going to go.
And I suspect that
this is a moving picture
and we haven't seen the last act yet.
But we can say this.
First of all,
what we've seen is extraordinary.
And I think you've seen cracks
emerge that that weren't there before.
First, in having Prigozhin raised
front and center
questioning the very premises
of the Russian aggression
against Ukraine to begin with.
The argument that somehow Ukraine
or Naito posed a threat to Russia
and a direct challenge to Putin himself.
So think about it this way.
16 months ago,
Russian forces were on the doorstep of
of Kiev, Ukraine,
thinking they were going to take the city
in a matter of days,
erase the country from the map.
Now,
they had to be focused
on defending
Moscow, Russia's capital,
against mercenaries
of Putin's own making.
So this raises lots of profound questions
that will be answered,
I think, in the days and weeks ahead.
I understand
this is very much a moving
and a fluid situation.
One thing that Senator Marco Rubio
said, he's,
of course, a top Republican
on the Intelligence Committee.
He says that
top military officials
in Russia
may have been
replaced in order
to get Prigozhin to back down.
Have any top military of many top
any top military officials, forgive me,
like the defense minister,
been ousted as far as the U.S. knows?
We we haven't seen that yet.
But again,
I think we'll see this unroll further
in the days and weeks ahead.
There's
no secret to the fact that Prigozhin was
very much a critic
of the
military leadership,
the minister of defense,
the head of the armed forces.
So how this now unfolds in terms of
personnel,
all of that remains to be seen.
We are intensely
focused on on Ukraine and making sure
that Ukraine continues
to have what it needs to defend itself
to take back the territory
that the Russians
have seized over the past 16 months.
And we're very focused
on maintaining
the unity of purpose in action
that has been a hallmark
of Ukraine's success to date.
The president brought together
not only the national security
cabinet yesterday,
but brought together leaders
from among our key allies and partners.
He instructed the rest of us
to fan out, to engage
all of our allies and partners,
to make sure we were closely
coordinating and keeping the focus
where it needs
to be
on Ukraine,
on the efforts
that they're making to take back
the territory that
Russia has taken from that.
I understand that.
But just a
saying on Vladimir Putin for a minute.
Do you believe that
this is the beginning of the end
for Vladimir Putin?
I don't want to speculate about that.
This is,
first of all,
an internal matter for Russia.
What we've seen is this, though.
We've seen this aggression
against Ukraine
become a strategic failure
across the board.
Russia is weaker
economically, militarily.
Its standing around
the world has plummeted.
It's managed
to get Europeans off of Russian energy.
It's managed to unite
and strengthen NATO's
with with new members
and a stronger alliance.
It's managed to alienate from Russia
and unite together Ukraine in ways
that it's never been before.
This is just an added
chapter
to a very, very bad book
that Putin has written for Russia.
But what's so striking about it
is it's internal
The fact that you have from within
someone directly
questioning Putin's authority,
directly questioning the premises
that upon
which he launched this aggression
against Ukraine,
that in and of itself is something very,
very powerful.
It adds cracks
where those go when they get there.
Too soon to say
But it clearly raises new questions
that Putin has to deal with.
You talked about Ukraine.
Of course,
Ukraine
did launch simultaneous counteroffensive
against several Russian fronts
while all of this was happening.
What is your understanding
of the latest on the ground in Ukraine?
And will
they be able to take advantage
of the chaos on the battlefield?
How much is the U.S. and U.S.
allies?
NATO's
leaning into the chaos
in order to take advantage
So these are early days
for the counteroffensive.
It's going to play out over weeks,
maybe even over months.
The Ukrainians have in hand what they
what they need to be successful
It's challenging.
It's a it's a tough terrain.
The Russians have put in place
lots of defenses
over the last months
in anticipation
of this counter-offensive.
But it is progressing
and to the extent
that Russia is now distracted,
that Putin has to worry
about what's going on inside of Russia
as much as he has to worry about
what he's trying to do.
Not successfully in Ukraine.
I think that creates
an additional advantage
for the Ukrainians to take advantage of.
But regardless,
they are pressing forward.
They have a clear plan.
They're pursuing it.
Well, and the Ukrainian foreign minister,
I know you heard this, he says it's time
for the US and others
to put a foot on the gas,
give Ukraine everything
it needs to finish this.
Is that going to happen?
Well, I spoke to my
my friend and counterpart, Dmitry Kelly,
but just yesterday
we speak we speak pretty regularly
and throughout
we have worked to make sure
that the Ukrainians have what they need,
when they need it
to do as well as they possibly can
on the ground. We'll continue to do that.
We're relentlessly focused on this.
There's tremendous unity of purpose
and unity of action
among dozens of countries
that through the president's leadership,
we brought together and kept together.
And we'll continue to do that.
Secretary Blinken, Russia
has nearly 6000 nuclear
weapons, the largest stockpile
in the world.
The situation
really revealed
that this very large
nuclear power
is facing some major instability.
Are you confident
that the nuclear weapons are secure?
And more broadly,
how concerned are you about
Russia being unstable right now?
Anytime you have
a major country
like Russia
that has signs of instability,
that's something of concern
and something that,
of course, we're very focused on
when it comes to their nuclear weapons.
We've seen no change in their posture
and we've made no change
in our own posture.
But it's something,
of course, we're looking at
very, very carefully.
On Vladimir Putin
last year, the president said,
for God's sake,
this man cannot remain in power.
Is that still the American position?
These are decisions
for the Russian people.
And this entire chapter
is an internal matter.
It obviously has profound repercussions
outside of Russia,
including potentially in Ukraine.
But fundamentally,
this is a Russian matter.
It's not our business.
It's not our purpose to choose
Russia's leaders.
That's up to the Russian people.
And we have
no no beef with the Russian people.
On the contrary, What is one of the many,
many tragedies
of what Putin has done in Ukraine
is what it's done to the Russian people.
And you really have to ask,
how is this in any way
improve the lives of Russians?
Of course, it hasn't.
It's made them worse.
But these are questions
that Russians
have to resolve for themselves.
I have to ask you about China.
You just went to Beijing last week.
It was an attempt to smooth,
frayed relations with China.
Two days later,
President Biden calls
Xi Jinping a dictator,
which angered China
so much that they issued
an official diplomatic
reprimand to the U.S.
ambassador.
Was the president wrong to call Xi
Jinping a dictator?
Then it
is very
clear that when it comes to China,
we are going to do
and say things that they don't like,
they are going to do and say things
that we don't like.
If you look at what comes out of
the Chinese foreign ministry
every day about the United States,
you'd hear plenty of that.
But the the purpose of the trip
at the president's instruction
was to try to bring a little bit
more stability to the relationship
to demonstrate
that we're committed
to managing it responsibly,
which really is an obligation for us
and an expectation
that countries around the world have
and to be able to deal very directly
with our differences.
There's no secret about
about those differences.
concerns we have about democracy,
about human rights,
about some of the actions
that China is taking around the world
and being able to have better, stronger,
sustained lines of communication means
we can talk about these differences
directly.
We can work through them where
where we can,
but at the very least,
avoid misunderstandings,
avoid miscalculations.
That's the fastest way
to go from the competition.
We're in to a conflict we want to avoid.
So I think on those terms,
the visit was was positive.
And again,
one of the things I told the Chinese is
that we're going to continue
to do things
and to say things that you don't like,
do you?
Just as you're to do
the same and we'll work through them.
Do you believe that Xi
Jinping is a dictator?
The president speaks clearly.
He speaks candidly.
I've worked for him
for more than 20 years
and he speaks for all of us.
Okay.
Secretary of State
Antony Blinken
thank you so much for joining us
this morning. Good to be with you, Don.